resounding support for stimulus and
innovation programs designed to lift
europe out of economic crisis and keep
it there politicians speak a lot of the
power of small to medium-sized
enterprises plus innovation and research
to create jobs for the 21st century and
on thursday they approved plans to boost
prospects first with an sme program to
cut running burdens and improve access
to funds we failed for a long time and
for the first time the parliament
did establish a specific budget for
smaller medium-sized companies
and a dedicated program much more
flexible
much more related to their business case
closer to innovation
and sticking with that topic only
billions of euros bigger there was
approval for key elements of horizon
2020 europe's seven year 70 billion
euros science and innovation program
this one involves smes now and operates
a collaborative knowledge base approach
moving towards a more
open uh knowledge system
and environment uh is is certainly
something that we need to do if we want
europe to innovate faster
that's the future this is the now and
here the task for meps is to help
europe's huge retail sector unlock its
full potential for growth jobs and
competitiveness retail is a pillar of
the single market but according to an
open hearing too many obstacles
distortions and inequities still exist
for it to function as intended that's
fairly and efficiently
like unfair payment systems big actor
dominance unfair trading practices that
hit small businesses in particular the
value of the smaller shop of the
independent retailer
who
takes enormous risks very often is still
especially in times of crisis
fighting a big fight that is very often
extremely important for the neighborhood
for the city or for the village